One thing that might have made you uneasy,
is that when we selected our header element, we simply chose a class name and
assumed it to be unique, or hoped it was.
Typically, you cannot make the assumption that a class name is unique
to a given element.
IDs are typically reserved as unique identifiers that don't show up
on any other HTML or DOM nodes throughout the page.
But classes could, and often are, applied to many different HTML tags.
We can test whether navbar static top
was indeed unique by using d3's selectAll function.
SelectAll works in just the same way as select.
Except for instead of returning one,
it returns all the elements that match the selection.
As you can see here,
I'm trying to select every header with class navbarstatic top on the page.
Luckily for us, what gets returned is a single element.